hi I'm David wood and I'm here with two
of the stars of the hit television show
Babylon 5.
so what roles do you guys have it's
Babylon
it's Bella V
the kind of
I mean that was a science fiction it
does say 90s it does say Babylon B but I
thought
that was uh like someone had
made
you know trying to make the five with
Roman numeral and said Babylon V and
then someone misheard it and said
Babylon B something like that but you
guys you guys actually went with
Babylon B there's literally a giant B
right but right behind your head and
that's the logo you came up with
it's a well it's a b uh
and that's the name wow a great one you
could do a spin-off of it the the
Nineveh Nat
that doesn't start with it
goodness gracious this is the most
boring start to an interview ever that
started with g
all right so you guys are the Babylon B
yes I thought that was yeah well it
sounds like it sounds like a spelling
contest in Iraq or
I see what you did there the town's
nickname for Nebuchadnezzar's wife
and so what what exactly do you guys do
not appropriate but where exactly
it's a so it's Christian
um Christian satire
we tell jokes we tell jokes
saying saying Christian satire itself
sounds like satire uh can I point that
out I mean it's like saying uh oh I'm a
Seventh-Day Adventist
cage fighter or
um I'm a Mennonite film critic or I'm an
Amish NASCAR driver
yeah yeah I've seen you guys you guys do
a bang-up job here well thanks
uh all right appreciate it appreciate it
and now I am bringing you up on Google
Wikipedia says
that you were suspended
from Twitter
for mislabeling a trans woman
how would you feel if someone mislabeled
you as talented and relevant
like I mean I feel like
I'll give I'll give that one to him I
mean it seems
pretty accurate
it's funny now let's get to know the
real
uh I'm sorry no one knows your names
yeah
should we we'd say why don't you say
your name I think people know your name
oh he doesn't Kyle Kyle
my name is Jared Kyle and Jared you
sound like NASCAR drivers
um let's get to know the real Kyle and
Jarrett um
when you were kids did you want to grow
up and become satirists or did you
actually have some sort of ambition to
make something of yourselves
I wanted to go to prison
that was good
well it's the first interesting response
you've given towards anything
the clink a famous person once said
satire is the last Refuge of a loser
who's drowning in his own failure how
does this quote perfectly describe your
work if we can call it work
I don't believe anybody said that who
said that I I just said it did you just
say yeah did you say it I am famous
what was your name again people know my
people know my face from YouTube people
know you from your lame tweets and you
don't even have those anymore unless
Daddy Warbucks swoops in like Superman
and saves your sorry hides
I go to the airport and people walk up
to me hey you're David wood
can I get a picture people walk up to
you and say hey
can you give me the gate for the red eye
to boring loserville because you're
obviously from there
all right well this has been one massive
disappointment
um so I apologize to all my viewers for
uh for talking to these guys on my
channel but I am going to be on their
Channel The Babylon Bay and that I
guarantee you will be a much more
fruitful productive discussion because
they will be talking to me and getting
answers from me rather than this
travesty that you've just witnessed so
click on the link
this
where did you find this guy